Hello everybody and welcome to episode
four of my road to one bill
series/progress video. Just as we start,
we're getting a farming level. We're
going for level 32 farming. Uh so we can
get the Renar going and yeah, we're
going to jump right into it here, but
we'll explain our goals a little bit
further into the episode. Okay, so we're
just about to hit 32 farming and now we
can finally farm Renar weeds. Uh we've
been kind of going forwards this for
quite a while, so it's kind of nice to
finally hit it. Okay, so we're going to
buy some Renar seeds. I'm just going to
buy four to begin with here. um because
that's the only patches we really have
available. And yeah, we're going to do a
little test run here. Then we'll
probably invest in more than four seeds
at a time. Um and yeah, let's go ahead
and uh do our run. Okay, so we just
finished the run. Um I think we got
pretty much down pat. I'll show you a
bit later exactly what I do. Um but
we're just using using the four patches.
Uh we're not using the Zoa one or the
Trollheim one yet. And uh we're just
selling off the Mortmire Fungus. Uh we
did a bit more of it just to get a
little bit more cash. Um, we got about
700 800k. Unfortunately, they're
actually dropping a bit. Now, I'm not
really sure if I did that. Hope not. Um,
but yeah, they've dropped a bit. So, uh,
what we want to get done this episode
for sure is Dragon Slayer, uh, which
we're going to be working on right now.
So, to start to dragon slayer, we need,
um, pretty much just a few more quest
points. Everything else we have. So,
we're going to do a really easy quest
that gets us five quest points, I think,
which is Goblin Diplomacy. And after
that, I think we're just going to start
Dragon Slayer.
I don't know why, but I always find this
cut scene really funny. Just the goblins
and their armor. They end up wanting the
same color they've always had, but um
yeah, maybe it's just me. And there we
go. The quest is done. Five quest
points, uh 200 crafting XP, and a gold
bar. Uh so that puts us at 34 quest
points. Uh which is perfect. We just
need 32. Okay, so we have pretty much
all the items ready now in the
inventory. And yeah, we're just going to
start by heading to the maze, I believe,
first. And yeah, we'll get this quest on
the We brought magic for the maze. Um,
just kind of wanted to train it, so I
don't know. We'll see how this goes.
There's 36 magic. We just got a magic
level, which is nice. And we're just
about to hit uh kill this lesser demon.
And yeah, we're almost through the maze.
And then we got to repair the ship. Um,
but I actually kind of enjoy this quest.
Okay, so we got all the map pieces and
we're just kind of repairing the ship
here, getting it seaorthy.
Just slam in the same place over and
over again. Um, there we go. Should be
already after that uh repair. Take that
back. I think this might be one of my
most favorite cutscenes. Look at this
high quality cut scene for Runescape.
Got dragons, got boat. My favorite parts
come up here. Look at that guy's legs.
H
and this guy just gets [__] But uh
yeah, we're good. And so we're going to
crash on the island and then we're going
to kill Elvar. Hopefully we brought an
anti- fire potion and we have protect
from magic and a bunch of lobsters. So
we're going to see how this goes. Uh
hopefully I don't die. Okay, I'm not
really sure how well this is going. Um
we're missing him so much and he's doing
quite a bit of damage to us. So I think
this gonna be kind of close. [__] me.
Oh, I wasn't paying attention and he
killed me.
H
I don't even think we can get back. We
have to rebuild the boat again. [__]
All right. Well, let's just go do it
again. Okay, we are back for round two.
I think we should be able to do it. The
only reason I died is because I was an
idiot and wasn't paying attention. Uh,
so yeah, I don't think we should have an
issue. Oh, well, my stuff's still on the
ground. Okay. Uh yeah, we got a lot of
food on the ground, too, which is nice.
Yeah, let's go slay this [__] dragon.
Okay, he is almost dead. Just one more
hit and then this quest is done. This
took quite a bit longer than it should
have just because I died, but um that
should be the final hit. And there we
go. Elvar has been slain. And we just
teleport over the wall.
Oh yeah, we're slicing off his head.
[__] yeah.
Boom. And there we go. That's pretty
much the end of the quest. And just
talking to Ozatch to finish the quest.
There we go. 18,000 strength and defense
experience. That is quite awesome. Let's
see what levels we get. And get rid of
this message.
Okay, so we got
four strength levels. Perfect. 44
strength and level 40 defense. That's
perfect. Um, now we can wear the rune
plate body. So, we're all set pretty
much. Okay, there's our armor set. Let's
equip it. Now we are officially
still a noob, but uh less of a noob,
which is going to be pretty nice for us.
Okay, so now I'm just going to do a farm
run. Um we bought a bunch of seeds, and
I'm going to show you exactly how I do
it. So what I need basically is um
Draymond staff. We need uh super
compost, which it looks like we've
actually forgotten.
[__] Okay, redo this. We'll have to go
back and get the super compost. You know
what? [__] it. We'll just do it without
the super compost. So anyway, um the
Draymond staff, you equip it. Um I go
from Edgeville, you run up um to the
fairy ring teleport, and then you go to
the fair ring code ALQ. You plant the uh
herb there, and then I teleport to
Drraanor. I'm just going to grab my
super compost, which I forgot. Uh the
super compost basically just give it the
herb a better chance of surviving. Uh so
then I teleport to drainer and I'm going
to run up to the Fowlor patch. Um, you
could teleport to Fowlor as well, but
um, I think they're pretty close in
distance, so it doesn't really matter.
Um, you're also going to want to make
sure you have your magic secretars,
which you got from the fair ring, fairy
tales part two quest. You want the
spade, and you need a rake sometimes,
and a seed diver. Need all that crap in
your inventory.
And, um, if you didn't know, the magic
secretaries give you 10 or 20% more of a
yield from your your herbs or any crops
anyway. Um, so it's quite nice to have.
You can see, um, normally you get at
least five, assuming the plant's dead,
but you can see I got like nine renars,
which is awesome. That's like 70 or 80k,
and the seed only cost me 20. So 60k
profit right there. Uh, so farming is
actually quite nice.
Now, after that, I go to the um farming
patch that's in um Tavernly. No, sorry.
Um, Catherby, Catherby. And, um, I'd use
a Camelot teleport to get there. Then
you just run over to the right a little
bit. And here is the other patch here.
And basically, I'll just, uh, pick these
herbs as well. And the final patch that
you can go to right away is just above
our dome. So, I use a combat bracelet
cuz I don't really have anything else
unlocked. All of these teleportation
methods do not require anything except
for the Draymond staff, of course. So
again, you're going to need the Draymond
staff for the fair ring teleport glory
charge to get the drainer, a combat
bracelet charge to get to the ranging
guild, which you can see I'm doing now.
And I'm just going to run down south
from there, and a Camelot teleport tab
or the actual runes if you actually have
the magic level, which I do not right
now, which is a little annoying. And
yeah, so from the ranging guild, you
just run a little bit south, and there
is the final plot. Uh, which is pretty
sweet. And we'll just harvest this and
plant the last seed. And that's pretty
much it. I've noticed you get about 15
to 20k on the average in profit per se.
Uh per run, you can range anywhere from
50 to 200k. It's pretty awesome. And
anyway, that's how I do it. It's pretty
easy early farming run. Okay, so we just
finished a farm run and uh that was the
last of the seeds we bought. Then we
bought 20 seeds and we bought them for
20k each. So 400k for all the seeds.
Now, this is the last of the herbs. So,
we'll see how much we actually got um in
yield from all those seeds. Um so, to
break even, we need at least I don't
actually know, but uh we got about 110.
And that's going to be worth sure
between 700 and 800k. So, it looks like
we'll be making about 300k at least.
doing the 20 Renar seeds, that was five
herb runs, which could be done in a day
easily, but it took me two because I
wasn't playing a whole lot.
Um, but yeah, and the other 21 herbs in
our Grand Exchange slot that we just
claimed was the first four seeds that
you saw in the previous clip. Um, those
were just a test run, did very well, so
we did the rest and we sold them all for
746k, so 350k profit. Okay, so we're
going to knock out another early quest.
um which gives it quite a bit of combat
experience and very easy to do. Only
takes like 10 or 15 minutes. That is the
uh fight arena.
I'm not sure. You'll see pretty soon.
Okay, so there is the ogre we're just
about to kill here. It's really easy,
especially because there's this skeleton
really conveniently in the middle that
lets you safe spot all the uh opponents.
Okay, there is the bouncer dead. I don't
know why it's called a bouncer. Okay, so
we're just pretty much done the quest.
Barely took any damage. It was really
easy. And there is 12,000 attack
experience and 2,000 demon experience.
Actually, that's pretty nice. That will
give us some thieven levels. Actually,
14 levels. That actually helps out quite
a bit for the early thieving.
Okay, so we're going to come train lava
dragons again just to get a couple more
magic levels. Okay, so here comes the
lava dragon kill. Let's see what we get.
And a two type of key. Actually, that's
pretty nice. That's about 30k right
there. And dead. And yeah, that's the
way it goes. So, that was definitely um
[__]
Why are there so many PKs there? There's
unreasonable amount of people trying to
PK there.
Okay, so what we're going to do now is
we're just going to level up some
fletching. I'm really busy today and I
just want to do a skill that's kind of
AFK. Plus, there is a moneymaking
method. Don't want to try it, but it's
about 60 fletching I require.
So, um I don't know. We'll get there
eventually and we'll start the grind
now. And there's level 10 fletching. Um
didn't take too long. Now we can make
long bows, which is pretty shitty still,
but we will get there eventually. Level
15 fletching. Um, took probably like 6
minutes, which is pretty sweet. I think
it's actually speeding up somehow. And
there's level 20 fletching. Now we can
craft oak short bows. Again, I don't
seem to be slowing down really much. And
there's level 25 fletching. Now we can
make oak long bows. At some point, this
becomes profitable, but not yet. And
there is level 30 fletching. And now we
have access to
uh steel arrows and some other [__]
that we don't need. Now I can make the
willow short bow. That would be level 35
fletching and level 40 fletching. Came
pretty quickly. Now we have access to
the willow long bow. Only 20 levels
left. So now we're on to stringing
willow longbows. Um it's way quicker.
It's going to cost a little bit of
money, but it's going to save me some
time. So I'm definitely going to do it.
It cost probably 50k in total to get
from level 40 to 55 or something like
that. And there's level 45 fletching.
That was much quicker. Definitely a good
call to start shringing the bows. Okay,
we are just about to hit 50 fletching.
It's definitely starting to slow down a
little bit. Um but I think we're going
to get 55 and then maybe move on to
something else for today. Okay, I think
that's going to be the last fletching
level of today. Had enough of it for
sure and that is going to be 55
fletching. So, we're still about seven
or eight levels off of the 63 I think we
need. And what we're planning on doing
is ruby bolt tips because I've heard
they're actually pretty good money. Or
diamond bolt tips. Any of those uh
emerald bolt tips, too. I mean,
whatever. Anything that would make us
money. And um but yeah, there's 55
fletching. I think we're actually going
to make a little bit of money off the
maple short bows. Not a lot, but more
importantly, we did not lose any money.
uh which is always exciting when it
comes to fletching. So yesterday I did
buy another 40 seeds and this is the
final seed of the run. So we're going to
see how much money I actually made from
40 seeds this time. Um and I still think
I got a little bit less than average,
but uh yeah, we'll go to the Grand
Exchange and actually see how much we
managed to make. Okay, so we're at the
Grand Exchange and we've gotten exactly
200 Ryar seeds. So it seems to be or
Graren weeds, sorry. But it seems to be
about 100 per 20 seeds. So about five
per seed. Uh which is not too bad. So
we're going to make probably between 6
and 700k from these Renareds. So quite a
good money-making method. I'm going to
probably work on next episode getting
the other patches available.
And um yeah, I think that's where I'm
going to call it for today, guys. I hope
you enjoyed. Uh again, if you're
enjoying the series, please leave it a
like. Um we getting quite a bit of likes
on the the episodes. Really awesome. I'm
glad you guys are enjoying it. Next
episode, we're going to get the ZA
farming patch. Um, and yeah, we're
probably get our combat level up, try to
get some other money-making methods.
We're ending the episode at pretty close
to 2 mil. Most of that profit just from
farming.
And um, yeah, hope you guys enjoyed.
I'll see you guys in the next episode.
[Music]